how's it going everybody it's Warren
happy day after Halloween hopefully
everybody is not feeling too bad this
morning last night we had some
interesting events happen events that
happen to involve Sony spider-verse I
know that there has been a lot of focus
on the sony disney deal over the
renegotiations of spider-man remaining
in the MCU which of course thank
goodness he is but let's not forget that
Sony has their own Sony verse they have
their own spider verse and that includes
venom soon to be carnage soon to be
Morbius and of course there's a lot of
talk about Kraven the hunter as well and
of course it includes spider-man into
the spider verse which of course was a
huge success for Sony and today we're
going to talk about Sony's T's for a
second into the spider verse film I'm
still doing my Xbox one and ps4 giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be
subscribed to my channel like the video
and comment below so as I mentioned last
night on Halloween in an interesting
turn of events the official Twitter page
for spider-man into the spider verse
tweeted something that caught our
attention the official Twitter page for
the movie tweeted something's up our
spidey sense is tingling retweet if
yours is too spider emoji now
everybody's first immediate reaction is
obviously to think of a sequel and that
is exactly what is happening here now
some people could write this off and say
oh they're perhaps teasing something
else but remember a sequel for the film
has already been confirmed producer Amy
Pascal has said it is official we are
getting a second movie and not to
mention right away immediately after the
tweet the official Twitter page for Sony
Pictures replied with a spider emoji and
then the official Twitter page for
Fandango replied with an ear listening
emoji and then after they replied the
official Twitter page for Sony Pictures
animation replied with 9 spider emojis
and then of course the official Twitter
page for Sony replied with an emoji of
somebody looking through an eyeglass so
this is not a coincidence a second movie
is coming and it's looking like it is
about to be announced by Sony and by
spider-man into the spider verse it's
interesting that they are going to
announce a sequel so soon spider-man
entered the spider verse only came out
less than a year ago on December 12th of
2018 but the film was a
extremely successful and sony has
mentioned that they do have plans for
their own spider-verse
in fact at one point in time when the
deal was dead between Sony and Disney
and spider-man was no longer in the MCU
they said that they're going to continue
to move forward with their own
spider-man film so it's very clear that
spider-man is a big focus for Sony right
now so much that it seems like we are
going to be getting a spider-man into
the spider-verse sequel soon what was
your favorite part of spider-man into
the spider verse let me know in the
comments down below also don't forget to
subscribe to my channel and like the
video so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
winners choice I'm also starting a
giveaway on Twitter and Instagram very
soon so follow me on there if you would
like to as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof